My first lecture on the
known world focused on the
question of knowledge and the
problems of knowledge that
the text raises for us, uh,
through out both at the formal
level and at the thematic level,
so I ended up with a reading of the
account of the Broussard trial and how
more and more detailed knowledge comes to
us through the voice of the narrator
and were really left for that question.
Where does that knowledge come from?
Now I suggested in the first lecture
that my second lecture was going to be
about an equally abstract subject and
that is how how can anything exist in the
world. I'm going to get that to that
about in the middle of the lecture.
Beginning from this question though where
we ended last time about the Broussard
trial and the problem of knowledge
where knowledge comes from.
If we look a little bit earlier in the
passage about the Broussard trial on one
7,172 you find what I think is quite a
striking model for the very problem of
this novel as a whole.
And this is when Skiffington
is trying to write an account
of Broussard's crime,
and here it is on the bottom of one 71
he's having trouble filling out this form.
Skiffington picked up
the list of questions.
Now he would have to start all over again.
Nature of the alleged crime.
Are there witnesses to the alleged crime?
Can such witnesses be believed?
So the problem of evidence and the
problem of whether witnesses are to be
trusted,
the problem of enumerating a crime,
these are all problems that the novel
as a whole takes up for the crime of
slavery.
Yeah.
So we can think of the novel itself as
a version of Skiffington [inaudible]
report.
Now it's important that Skiffington
has such a problem writing it.
The very difficulty of writing is the
Matteis over and over and over again.
Not just in moments like this where
it's actually talking about writing,
but I'm going to argue,
uh,
in a number of ways that are much more
subtle and to show you one of them.
I want to look on one side,
one 92 with you.
This is the scene where Stanford,
the slave is trying to remember
the names of his parents
and this is how he does it.
This is the middle of one 92.
Yeah.
He closed his eyes and took his parents
in his hands and put them all about the
plantation where he had last seen them,
his mother in his left hand and
his father in his right hand,
but that did not feel right.
And so he put his father in his left
hand and his mother in his right hand and
that felt better.
He set them outside the smoke house,
which had a hole in the roof in the back.
Hands come down that hole
and take you to the devil.
And older boy had once told him Stanford
was five and it had been on not been
long since his parents had been sold away.
And you get more of the story.
And he finally,
uh,
to remember the parents' names,
his parents' names.
Why does he take them
in these specific hands?
His father in his right hand
and his mother in his left
that did not feel right.
So he put his father in his left
and his mother in the right.
I would argue that this is for
two reasons, a figure of Jones,
his own writing. Uh, first of all,
in the obvious sense that it's an act
of recovery of recovering a past that
needs to be imagined or
somehow entered into,
not through rational thought,
but through an imaginative act.
So that's one reason that Stanford
in this moment is a double of Jones.
But the other reason is this
handedness that's noted.
Uh, I'm going to tell you throughout
the lecture a few things about Jones,
his life and his work
outside of this novel.
And so here's the first
piece of that story. Um,
Edward P.
Jones was the son of a very
poor single mother living in DC.
He had a younger brother
who was mentally disabled,
who had to be given away to an institution
because the mother could not support
him. Uh, Jones, his mother was illiterate.
Okay.
So here is someone writing this novel
and his background is an illiterate
mother.
This matters enormously to him.
He in his first story
collection and has, uh, has a,
a story called,
I think it's called first day,
where he tells the story of a young girl
going off to school for the first time,
holding the hand of her illiterate mother
Jones reveres his mother when he talks
about her.
Uh,
it's with incredible reverence and love.
Jones sees his mother very much
as a source of his writing.
So here's that first tension in the of
writing that here is a writer who takes
as his source spiritual source,
an illiterate woman.
That's why the mother has to go
in his right hand in this scene.
Now. Um, of course not everybody
writes with their right hand,
but I think no matter whether
Jones his right or left handed,
and I think Andy Hazel for
pointing out our wonderful ta,
Andy Hazel for pointing out that in the
photograph of Jones he is wearing his
watch on his left hand.
And so this would suggest
that he is perhaps right handed,
but even if we didn't want to rely,
Oh Neil,
you're going to give me trouble.
Um,
even if you did not want to rely
on that little piece of evidence,
we can say that in the cultural
vocabulary of handedness,
the dominant hand is the
right hand for writing.
So I would say that whenever you see
right handedness or left to right movement
Jones is meditating on and
figuring the act of writing.
And I'm going to show you some more
examples because it's quite striking.
It's subtle and strange
but quite striking. So the,
the mother has to go on the right hand
because she is the source of inspiration.
The Father Jones,
his father was very distant.
He only met him when he was much older
and he was not really a part of Jones his
life at all. Uh, it really
revolved around his mother.
So if writing is undermined by the
shadow of illiteracy for Jones,
it's undermined in other ways too.
And I want to look at one
of those stranger episodes.
This is on one 40 to one 43.
Okay.
Um,
this was the story of how Henry began
to court Caledonia at for Nelsons dinner
table. And this is a very, um,
detailed scene.
This is in the middle of one 42.
He's telling Caledonia that she needs
to look up when she rides her horse.
He took the pepper
Shaker in his right hand,
extended his arm before him and
move the arm from right to left.
Everyone at the table
was now watching him.
The hand with the Shaker moved smoothly,
gracefully from the right to the left.
That's how everyone else,
everybody else rides. Henry
said, me and everybody else,
Henry put the pepper Shaker in
his left hand, tipped it and Ooh,
moved his arm less gracefully from
the left to the right as it moved,
pepper poured out of the shaker onto
ferns, white tablecloth. He said,
I'm sorry to say this,
but that's how you ride.
Henry did this with the Shaker several
times going from right to left,
the pepper Shaker was upright,
but going from left to right,
the pepper flowed down for and thought
there was something rather sad about the
pepper falling and it was all the sadder
because it really didn't have to be
that way. She said to Anderson,
the pamphlet here from Canada,
it was, this was his clumsy
way of telling Caledonia.
She was losing something
by not looking up.
How odd that insistence on
the movement left to right,
right to left.
It figures Henry's mixed up relation to
both language and the act of creation.
It's mixed up because when he's moving
in the direction that text is read,
read and written left to right,
he's using his left hand and the,
the uh,
corroborative of that left handedness
of his relation to language is in the
dialect. He doesn't speak
correctly in fern Alston's house,
no matter how hard she tries to teach him.
Okay,
so he is clumsy not only in
spilling pepper on the table,
but also in not being able
to speak proper English.
But the other thing about that movement
is that when it goes left to right,
pepper spills on the table, this is
an image of ink flowing out of a pen.
It is black on the white tablecloth and
it's an image for language in jeopardy
because of course it's dust, it's
powder, it will never cohere.
It's the sign of his
uncouth table manners.
So it's never going to be a redemptive
medium for him and it's represented by
this pepper that then he can
a scrape into a little pile.
This is the fragmentation of
language in it's very literal sense.
Yeah.
There are other examples of this.
I'm in one 80 on one 89 when you get
the first account of the frozen dog that
Calvin is so interested in
in the photograph from New York.
Yeah.
Once again,
direction is,
is carefully noted in the front yard
alone was a dog looking off to the right.
The dog was standing its tail sticking
straight out as if ready to go at the
first word from someone on the
porch and I'm going to skip down.
He had a very tiny hope that
when he got to New York,
he might be able to find the house and
those people and that dog and learn what
had transfixed him.
There was a whole off to the right that
the photograph had not captured off to
the right is the direction of
flowing narrative, a world,
a possible world that his imagination is
drawn to and it's a visual image of the
imagination and it's seduction,
but because of this obsessive direction
noting I would read it as a textual
imagination that there's a narrative off
to the right and you can see that Jones
is novel,
works this way.
There's always a narrative
proximate to wherever you are,
a little narrative that arises from the
next character who shows up on the road
and you'll get that narrative.
So this is just one of those that
doesn't quite get articulated,
but Calvin can imagine that it's there.
He can see as if he can see the form
of the novel that Jones is writing.
And then there are just even
tinier ones on one 62 um,
this is John Skiffington
sitting and reading the Bible.
After visiting Clara's house,
Skiffington looked up and followed a
male cardinal as it flew from the left to
right and settled in
one of the peach trees.
They're all over the place
once you start noticing them.
So I think this is why that it's a
constant meditation among the multiplying
versions of meditations on the composition
of this novel within the novel.
So we'll get to some others.
The problem is that the written
word is always threatened.
So if writing has all this
static that surrounds it,
it also has some more direct
and aggressive enemies.
And on three 75,
you see one version of that.
This is the account of Barnum Kinsey's
grave marker that his son makes
after they leave Manchester
County and he dies.
This is the bottom of three 74 Matthew
stayed up all the night before he was
buried.
This is Kenzie son putting his
father's history on a wooden tombstone.
He began with his father's name on the
first line and on the next he put the
years of the father's coming and going.
Then all the things he
knew his father had been,
and then lists this whole set of things.
The boy filled up the whole piece of wood
and at the end of the last line he put
a period his father's grave would remain,
but the wooden marker would not last out.
The year text is fragile
as a material object.
So that's what this scene
tells us in a poignant way.
But of course the most poignant example
of this is when Augustus is free.
Papers are eaten by Travis.
So the real terror of the
written word comes in that scene.
Now the terror is of course
that it's an exercise of power,
arbitrary,
violent.
It will end in Augustus's
death back in slavery.
There are lots of ways of
imagining what the terrorism,
I'm going to go into some of them,
but this is the sign of it
that even though Augustus
has memorized every word of
his free papers,
remember we're told that he has them
read to him every day for a month.
He's illiterate.
He has them read to him every day
for a month until he has them totally
memorized,
after he gets his freedom,
even though those words
will exist forever.
In Augustus's mind,
his freedom is nowhere once
the written word has gone.
So this is my question. How can
something exists in the world here?
The ultimate thing to which that
question applies is freedom.
How can freedom exist?
What makes Freedom Exist?
Well,
in the law, those free papers
make freedom exist for Augustus,
but the law cannot guarantee
that freedom exists.
When the physical artifact
of the text is gone.
That's how weak writing is.
It seems to be everything.
This is something that Mildred understood,
uh,
quite early on,
on one 13,
when she and Augustus are worried
about Henry hanging out with Robin's,
she says in suggesting that it's okay
to let Henry go about with William
Robbins, them free papers. He
carried with him all over the place.
Don't carry enough freedom.
She said to her husband
with slavery behind him,
she wanted her son to go about and
see what had always been denied him.
Yeah.
So she wants the world to
be a big place for him.
She sees that freedom is something
much more than those papers.
But the problem is that freedom cannot
be without them and that once they're
gone,
it is gone too.
So that is one of the threats
that is associated with writing,
but there are more of them.
Um,
on three 11 and three,
12,
one danger is that it's simply in
the effort to write justice in law.
It's simply ineffective.
So here is the story we get of
Skiffington trying to write up this crime,
the crime of selling Augustus,
a free man back into slavery.
This is on three 12. Um,
he's been in contact with,
uh,
a man named Sanderson in,
I think it sees in Georgia.
You got a letter from Sanderson three
days after that the crime had indeed been
committed.
He wrote and Sanderson included material
he had copied from book saying so.
So skiffington wasn't sure
whether it was really a crime.
Somehow he began to get confused and you
can see that confusion. I won't read it,
uh, on the prior page on three
11 in the middle of the page. Um,
so when Skiffington once again starts
writing up the crime, he becomes confused.
Did he really have a crime to describe?
He gets confirmation that he does,
but skiffington heard from Richmond.
Yes. It's a letter from Richmond again,
four days later in handwriting,
he did not recognize a grace.
Yella Sanderson let him know that her
husband Harry was dead and that he was now
she was now charged with
keeping up his correspondence.
He read the eight page letter twice,
but he found nothing in it
about what Virginia was doing,
about the crime of selling free negroes.
The widow told him about her husband,
how she had met him when he vacationed
in Italy, how he had wooed her,
brought her to America after their
wedding and made her a happy woman in
Richmond quote where the governor is in
residence quote and then she closes with
comments about the weather.
Yeah,
so the law's effort to deliver justice
through the writing of a crime.
The documenting of a crime is displaced
by a woman's effort to recover her last
husband by telling that story.
So there are competing claims
on language in this scene,
the widows and Skiffington ins and more
distantly Augustus's and Mildred's.
None of these claims are adjudicated in
any kind of way that puts one above the
other. And skiffington
is weakness, of course,
is that he will never seek to right.
That balance,
he resigns himself to
the weakness of writing
more chillingly.
I think more complicating Lee
writing also carries the risk of
reinstating the master slave relationship
and I think it does this by direct
reference back to Jones himself.
If you read slowly through the scene of
Augustus being sold back into slavery,
it's quite striking.
The way contingency or happenstance
plays a part in the scene.
So after Travis has
eaten Augustus's papers,
this is at the very bottom of two 12 a
wagon twice as large as Augustus's came
up to the four men driving.
It was a large black man and beside him,
a much smaller white man.
And Travis teases Darcy,
the slave trader about how he's
never known the time in his life,
but suddenly here he is
at exactly the right time.
Then he later says,
as he's formulating the idea
of selling Augustus to Darcy,
he says,
God works in mysterious ways.
This ain't exactly what I had in
mind when I stopped this nigger,
but this year we'll do just the same.
Who made that wagon appear?
Why does that wagon appear?
Jones made that wagon appear.
What we're given is not a fiction about
Travis intending to sell Augustus back
into slavery,
but what we're given instead
is a surprise on the road.
Who makes that surprise
appear only one person,
the person in charge of
making the narrative.
So the problem with writing is not
just that it's shadowed by the fact of
illiteracy. It's not just that
it's vulnerable to physical decay.
It's not just that it's weak and it
can't make anything exist in law.
It's not just that it's
demanded by multiple people
for different purposes that
come to cancel each other out.
It's that by writing,
by taking on that
quality of masterfulness,
you begin to be complicit in the
very crime that you're describing.
The imagery of God looking down on his
creation is everywhere in this novel.
And it's to all kinds of characters,
uh,
including,
including Henry who thinks that he will
look down on his slaves the way God
looks down on his creation from heaven.
That position of mastery
and that geographic remove
of being above your subject
is associated with the slave master,
but it's associated very much with Jones.
And I'll come back to this, uh, in a
minute when I talk about the tapestry,
because of course the tapestry at the
end of the novel Alesis tapestry is the
most dramatic figure for the whole novel.
There are lots of figures for the novel,
including the map of the known world,
but foremost that tapestry at the end,
which mimics the,
the novel in,
in every way.
Even that has the perspective
of little figures looking up.
So it even puts Alice in that masterful
position or indeed anyone who looks upon
that tapestry.
So if writing is so weak,
if it entails such terror,
are we given any alternative
for creative durability?
And I think we are in
the plastic arts now. Uh,
I'm sure you've noticed how much
carving goes on in the book,
not just because Augustus is a
woodworker, but you know, because, uh,
Elias carbs for Celeste,
that's his first act of love.
And if you read John's a story,
this is a rampant in his stories.
He has carvers everywhere and
various kinds of workers in,
in plastic arts. Alice's, another
example, working in textiles,
clay paint some amalgamation
of a sculpture and painting.
Yeah.
On to 79,
the two arts,
the verbal art and woodworking are
put in competition with one another or
injects to position with one
another. And I think you see, uh,
who has the upper hand here.
This is an account of
Skiffington bookcase,
which Augustus made.
Yeah.
In winter, Fred and John
Skiffington, his parlor,
there was a wondrous
looking bookcase case,
lovely oak alions Groundling face at
each edge of the top ends three shelves,
the second hand item made by Augustus
towns in La not long after Augustus bought
his freedom.
He had first thought he would keep it
for himself and the family he would buy
out of slavery,
though none of them could read them.
He and Mildred would never learn to read.
There's that shadow of our
attention is called to it.
The minute the books are mentioned,
he would keep it as a kind of symbol
for his determination to get them.
But then he realized that what he could
get for the bookcase would bring his
wife and child closer to him.
So he put a price on it, $15.
It had been originally sold to a man
of two slaves who lost his sight.
Another risk to reading.
You can go blind.
And so as he told Skiffington lost
his hunger and thirst for books.
Skiffington bought it for $5.
Augustus's art is durable.
It can be passed from person to person
and it maintains it's figurative power.
It's important that all
of his work is figurative.
It suggests narrative.
And so it's aligned with
Jones art in that way,
but it is not subject to
the vulnerability of texts.
And here in this bookcase you see the
vulnerability of texts set right next to
the wondrous durability of the bookcase.
There are other examples,
um,
when Rita is discovered and
the box of walking sticks,
when she sent in a box out
of slavery to New York,
she hands the boy who
is looking down at her,
the walking stick with Adam and
eve and all their generations.
It's as if in that act,
Rita's freedom is instantiated,
that she and all her descendants
emerge into this new world.
And that that is a kind of gift to the
family that takes them in, in the north.
So it has a very evocative narrative power
that doesn't depend on people's being
able to read it.
And we're told in that scene that the
boy receives it as if this is what he had
been waiting for.
All along suggests a perfect receptivity.
No going blind here.
Perfect receptivity.
Okay.
Uh,
there is also on to 19 one of Augustus's
chairs that I think is worth looking
at.
Yeah.
This
is when Travis is reflecting on or,
or we're being told about how
Travis first came to know Augustus.
He had first come to know Augustus
towns in many years ago through a chair
Augustus had made for a white
man in the town of Manchester.
The man weighed more than 400 pounds
and then I'm skipping down in the man's
parlor was Augustus as chair. Plane, not
even painted, but smooth to the touch.
And when the man sat in it, the chair
did not complain, not one squeak.
It just held up and did its job waiting
for the to put on another 300 pounds.
Travis examined the chair,
looked all about it,
trying to discover it's secret.
The chair gave nothing.
It was a very good chair.
Was a chair worth stealing?
The chair gave nothing.
Well,
it gave nothing in terms
of knowledge to Travis.
It would not give up its
secret of durability.
And that's in a way what makes it durable,
that it can hide the essence of itself.
Keep it to itself.
It takes the weight without one squeak.
It's very silence is what marks.
It's in vulnerability.
It's also what enrages a man like Travis.
So the novel sets up a
competing set of art forms,
carving foremost among them
against the art form of language.
The tapestry at the end answers one of
our questions from the first lecture,
which is, who knows, the
known world known by whom.
What we come to find out is that Alice,
although she seemed insane,
is the one who knows Manchester County.
She has walked all over it in the
freedom carved out by her insanity.
One thing that's interesting about,
uh,
Alice is that she,
despite her insanity seeming insanity,
is the one most in
control of her language.
She is the most successful
storyteller in this novel.
So if you think of other alternatives,
Moses,
he tells Caledonia stories
that finally failed
to persuade her imagination that
any slave she owns could be free.
We're told explicitly as Calvin tries
to persuade her at the end of the novel
that it's her failure of imagination that
keeps her from emancipating her slaves
after Henry's death.
Despite all of Moses stories,
she still cannot see him or
anyone else as a free person.
So Moses is,
storytelling is,
it is a complete failure in this way,
but how Ellis' storytelling about
the mule that kicked her in the head,
we find that out early in the novel.
That's the story about her.
That's why she said to be
crazy was we're told so vivid,
so sad that everybody believed it.
The very control she has over her crazy
are what persuades the whole world
around her that she's not worth bothering
with as she wanders around
the roads with impunity.
Yeah.
It also gives her occasion
to mock the master,
the structure of slavery,
the patrollers,
and she can do it with impunity as well.
So she has a freedom of mind as well as
a freedom of movement that nobody else
in the novel has who was a slave.
So she has doubly marked as an artist
in language and in the plastic arts,
but she's importantly,
uh, I think not a writer.
You'll note if you look at three 84,
three 85,
where the tapestry is described,
there still some whiff of that fragility.
Um,
and I see that in the admonition that
is hung next to the tapestry and that
Priscilla repeats.
When Calvin reaches out to touch it,
she says,
please do not touch.
There's that sense that this is still
something that needs to be protected.
Now why the terror?
Why the fragility?
Well,
I think this has a lot to do
with how this novel was composed.
Edward P.
Jones wrote his first book of
short stories in the 1990s,
in the early nineties.
I can't remember the date exactly.
And it was very successful,
but not successful enough to support him.
So he worked as an editor at
a journal called tax notes.
It was a journal of tax law.
Scintillating Jones was working there.
And I'm going to tell you a story now
that he tells in some of his interviews,
but I heard first from his agent,
a guy named Eric Simon off, um,
who I had up to visit one
of my classes. Um, when we,
uh, we're studying this novel, um,
Eric says that he heard from Edward that
Edward had this idea for a novel about
a black slave owner,
but he said, you know,
don't tell anyone this
is a stealable idea.
So, you know, Eric,
when he went down to DC would occasionally
stop in over the years and see Edward
and he'd say, how's the novel going? Hmm.
Didn't seem to be much on paper
and time passed 10,
10 years or so.
And Eric Thought,
you know,
I'm not sure if this novel
is ever going to get written.
In the meantime,
John's had amassed about 125
books of history of the period,
uh,
that he's working in,
in the novel because he felt that
in order to write a novel like this,
he really needed to master that history.
It was very intimidating to him though.
So that combined with his tax notes job,
he had about 12 pages written.
So he went on vacation after a long time.
He hadn't had a vacation.
He had about a six week vacation.
He finally got a start and one of the
ways that he got himself to start was he
decided that he was going
to forget about the history.
He was going to make it all up.
So all the historical sources,
if you read the back of the book,
you will know this.
All the historical sources are
fictional here. The census reports,
every detail is fictional.
So that was his first move.
Then he got laid off from text
notes right after this vacation.
Edward P. Jones then wrote
this novel in three months.
Yeah.
And Eric says that it became clear to
him over the years that Jones had in fact
memorized entire chapters
of what became this novel.
It was all in his head,
all the words in their order.
And so when he had the time and when
he freed himself from the obligation to
history out at came.
I think this says a lot about the images
of writing that you see all over the
novel.
Imagine the kind of terror that you would
feel knowing that you had all this in
your mind and knowing also that
it didn't yet exist on paper,
that you had only 12 pages.
Maybe if you're writing papers now you
feel this terror of the blank page.
It's possible.
Okay.
That's a real terror for a writer.
Combine that with the
shadow of illiteracy,
the feeling of possible betrayal for
a son to be a writer when his beloved
mother had no access to the written word.
This is a very vexed,
complex psychological relationship that
I would suggest my guests is that it has
a lot to do with how he,
the relative fragility and the relative
power of fiction versus these other
arts.
So Jones models his narrative on those
other arts in an effort to solve the
problems that are presented by the
terror of the written words. Fragility.
It's very uneasy relation to existence.
Does a novel exist?
Does it not?
And I think there's actually even a figure
for Jones in a particular character,
one of these tiny characters on uh,
three 43.
Okay.
Uh, this is a young man with a
wonderfully complicated mind.
MMM.
Wilson had learned a great deal at
that university in his mind would have
contained even more but well,
and his second year of the cadavers began
to talk to Wilson and what they said
made far more sense than what
his professors were saying.
The professors being gods did not like
to share their heaven with anyone dead or
alive. And they sent the young man
home in the middle of his second year.
Here
you see a figure for someone
whose imagination is so
powerful that it makes the
dead talk.
And think back again to the image of
Stamford finding by placing the image of
his parents all over the mansion,
all over the plantation,
finding their names.
That's a little like, uh,
talking to cadavers, they
are dead. Those parents,
it verges on insanity.
This is another problem with the
mode of composition that a mind,
this powerfully populated by an
alternate reality comes to look insane.
And I think this is another reason why
Alice is what she is as a character.
If she's going to be one of
the major doubles for Jones,
her insanity is part of that picture.
We can think of it as a willed insanity,
but it has the residue of doubt about it.
Maybe she really is insane to some degree.
Is there a sharp line
between and imagination that
can produce a narrative so
thoroughly populated as
this one and a narrative,
uh, and a mind that, uh,
sees cadavers talking to you.
Another thing that is remarkable
about Jones, his work, and um,
this relates back to what I was saying
about postmodernism and grand narrative
last time.
Jones's work is
seemingly very fragmented.
There are lots and lots of narratives,
but they don't all come
together in one narrative.
So it seems fragmented and
when you start to read it,
it looks disorienting.
If you read his stories,
you will see that all the stories are
interconnected back to the novel to Jones
his life. So for instance,
in all antique ours children,
his most recent story collection,
I think it came out in 2007 there is a
woman who has a walking stick that is
clearly made by Augustus
in the 20th century.
Yeah.
What I was saying about the durability
of the plastic arts is imagined in that
quality of his fiction,
these objects of carving
turnip throughout his stories.
Also, people are related to
each other in separate stories.
They're related to people in this novel.
The title of this novel appears in a
story called tapestry in all and Hagar,
his children,
he is obsessive about putting
the locations of all the
places that he lived in
DC into his stories perfectly accurately.
When an editor at the New Yorker tried
to get him to change one of these
descriptions and the address in one of
the stories that he submitted for the
magazine, he was very resistant. He,
he finally changed it for the New Yorker,
but when it went into
the story collection,
it went back because he wanted to be
absolutely accurate to what it was like
when he lived there. What it actually
looks like on that corner in DC,
what I think Jones is doing in the
largest version of his project is actually
one of the most wide reaching
and ambitious unifying
efforts that I know of in
contemporary fiction.
So this is not about the
fragmentation of grand narrative.
It's about the enormous large
scale accumulation of wholeness.
He is piecing a world together bit by
bit by bit as he adds to his literary of,
so this is a vision of unity that
goes way beyond generic boundaries.
Is it a short story?
Is it a novel?
This is something more like an opus that
Jones is building and more importantly,
it's something that lives in his
mind very clearly. These people,
these characters live in his mind.
There is no one doing
what Jones is doing today.
If there's something truly postmodern,
I would say Jones is it.
He looks very different
from what comes before him.
And modernism and it's a
ascendancy in the mid 20th century.
He is making pretty dramatic
claims for the power of fiction,
for the power of narrative
to put the world together.
Okay.
But at the same time,
as I've noted,
acknowledges the very
difficulty of that project,
the very weakness that lies at its heart.
And I think that's what for me,
makes his work extremely powerful.
That for all its ambition,
we are never allowed to forget.
It's ambivalence
that ambivalence is always there on the
surface and it's bodied fourth in the
kinds of moral problems
that this novel dwells upon.
The question of how human
love can exist in slavery,
whether it can exist all
it's complicated forms,
what the forms of freedom look like,
how freedom can possibly exist,
how you build it,
how it can be maintained.
All these things are there in an
incredibly ambitious literary form.
That's what Jones is doing that
nobody else is doing at this moment.
So I will stop there and we will think
about what forward is doing on my,
I will think about what
forward is doing on Monday.